hey guys today we're going to talk about
vitamin b deficiency okay
this is actually way more common than
you might think
the problem is when you do testing on
this a lot of times it won't show up in
the blood because the problem or the
defect
is in the enzyme that allows b1 to work
and just if you wanted to get it tested
the enzyme you would
get tested for would be trans-keto lace
okay it's just an enzyme that
works with b1 in doing its function okay
so
but the problem is trying to find a lab
that will test it's quite difficult but
anyway
here's what b1 does generally it does a
lot of things
but it's involved in five different
enzymes it's a cofactor
and five enzymes enzymes are the things
that do the work
in the body they're the workhorse it's
involved in all sorts of
bile body chemistry or chemical
reactions especially in the mitochondria
which is
energy factory so b1 is essential
to make those enzymes work so if you're
deficient in b1 the enzymes don't work
and you're going to get
fatigue is probably the most common
symptom when you take vitamin b1
it seems to bring your energy right up
most of the time
and instead of going out and getting a
test it's much cheaper just to take b1
and see if you feel better
chances are you're going to feel better
so in the next section i'll talk about
where to get b1 how much to take but in
this section i'm going to talk about
how many different systems it's involved
with
b1 deficiency is called berry berry and
it's
known as the great mimicker of disease
because it mimics so many other body
situations
it's incredible it's very widespread i
think
probably if you are pre-diabetic if you
have insulin resistance
if you're a diabetic you have a b1
deficiency
if you drink alcohol on a regular basis
you probably have a b1 deficiency if you
have a high carbohydrate diet
you probably have a b1 deficiency
because that's how you
develop a b1 deficiency so you
definitely need b1 when you actually
digest carbohydrates so too many refined
carbs
are going to deplete that so it's
involved in making energy
it's also involved in protecting the
cell
and the mitochondria against oxidation
or free radicals it's kind of considered
an antioxidant
it also protects the cell against
glycation which is basically when you
combine
a sugar with a protein or a sugar with a
fat
it develops like sticky protein it also
protects you
against developing amyloid plaquing in
the brain that's what you see in
alzheimer's so it's kind of like a
a protein that clogs up the brain's
neural function
there's an incredible book um by dr
derrick longsdale md it's i got the
kindle book it was like 79 dollars very
expensive
well worth it i could not stop reading
it
fascinating now the first system i'm
going to talk about
is the cardiovascular and respiratory
system
these are some of the symptoms that you
can develop if you're b1 deficient in a
large
heart because the heart has to work
harder
and then what happens is the heart gets
bigger and bigger
uh increase pulse rate edema
usually in the lower ankles and things
so you press
your lower ankle and you get this
indentation you see that a lot in
diabetics
microvascular damage your nerves need a
blood supply
so if you're deficient in b1 you're
going to starve
the food supply to the nervous system
that's why you see something called
peripheral neuropathy tingling burning
and numbness
and pain on your fingertips or the
bottom of your feet
okay so now let's go to the digestive
system you'll feel a full sensation in
your stomach like you're always kind of
stuffed
you can get constipated gastroparesis
now what is that
that's a condition where your digestive
system is very sluggish
foods going through very very slow
gerd which is kind of like a the valve
on the top of the stomach doesn't close
and you get acid that comes up through
this way now these two conditions really
come from low stomach acids hydrochloric
acid
and so vitamin b1 deficiency will create
a situation where you have
lower hcl hydrochloric acid thereby
causing
a sluggishness in the digestive system
and
causing gerd because it takes an acid
stomach to keep that valve
closed okay so you can see that it's
just so widespread it just goes way over
here and it goes way over here
and then the nervous system we talked
about peripheral neuropathy but just
neuritis in general
any type of nerve pain or nerve damage
that's occurring
b1 is very intimately involved in that
okay vertigo which is kind of a
dizziness when you actually stand up too
fast or even when you're standing
and you feel like you know you're on a
ship that could be coming from a b1
deficiency
and then it affects something called the
autonomic nervous system this is like
the
the combination between the sympathetic
nervous system and the parasympathetic
nervous system
and these are the two systems that work
on automatic so they do a lot of
different things so you can imagine how
many different symptoms
can occur from a problem within this
system
it's a very wide spread lack of tears
okay
excessive sweating or no sweating okay
a lot of people have that and they don't
really know what it is and it's hard to
find
the cause of that but usually it's a b1
deficiency
anxiety especially nervous tension
can't relax excessive thinking brain
fog exercise intolerance
i mean how many people have a resistance
to exercise right they
they just don't feel like they have the
energy to exercise
b1 insomnia you can't sleep
a condition called pots pots is a
condition where
um your your ability to adapt
to gravity and positional change is like
completely ruined because the autonomic
nervous system
especially the sympathetic nervous
system is dysfunctional so when you
stand up
the blood flow does not um keep up into
the brain
and you just get dizzy all the time so
you basically have to lay around all day
you can't quite get up
and down without feeling dizzy so
these people absolutely positively
should never go on a roller coaster
because that would really
mess them up but this is a b1 deficiency
fascinating sleep apnea because the
nerves that are affected in the brain
stem
control the respiratory centers so if
those are not working because there's
not enough b1
you can have problems breathing and even
just breathing in general is going to be
a problem like you're going to feel like
you
can't get enough air and that's for not
just for this reason there's a couple
other ones we'll get to
panic attacks b1 deficiency
nightmares at night classic b1
deficiency lack of stamina
just you know especially when you're
exercising you just you just
you don't feel like you want to exercise
because you just run out of gas real
fast
why because b1 is intimately involved in
five enzymes in your mitochondria so if
those enzymes aren't working
your mitochondria is tired and all the
different autoimmune diseases
usually have a common symptom of fatigue
that's usually the b1 so if you have
hashimoto's or ms and you're tired
take some b1 and see if you don't just
feel a lot better
a buildup of lactic acid see b1
helps get rid of lactic acid which is a
byproduct
of something in your metabolism in the
mitochondria
so if you don't have b1 you can't clear
it out so you build up lactic acid you
get this condition called lactic
acidosis
so you see that in a restless leg
syndrome you see that too
in people that have problems breathing
if you're a diabetic for example and
you're taking metformin
one of the side effects is lactic
acidosis that's why they actually have a
black label which is a more severe label
that it can cause this condition well
the reason why it causes that condition
is because
one of the side effects of metformin
is a b1 deficiency makes sense so you
can't get rid of the lactic acid so it
builds up
and you start becoming more acidic and
then you have breathing
problems recurrent ear infections
interesting you have a problem with
excess estrogen
uh the worst type of estrogen you can
have uh too much of is estradiol
so without enough b you can't
clear it out because one of the
functions would be one is to
get rid of excess estradiol from your
liver
okay this next one let me explain is
called ross i'm not going to get into
exactly
what it is but just realize it's an it's
like a free radical
oxidation particle okay and it's
developed by your cells
and b1 helps to reduce that oxidation
remember it's an antioxidant
so you'll have greater amounts of ross
if you don't have enough b1 now
when a woman is pregnant and she's
delivering a baby
there's a condition called toxemia which
is very dangerous for the baby and the
mother
the organs start becoming toxic and
the heart becomes a problem the kidneys
become an issue high blood pressure
and even it's life-threatening as well
so b1
will help prevent toxemia okay so the
beta cells or the pancreas are affected
those are the cells in the in the
pancreas that basically make
insulin so without enough b1 you're not
going to make enough
insulin if you're type 1 diabetic you
need
a lot of insulin because diabetics they
can't really absorb b1 too well so they
have to take even
more than the average healthy person
okay so stress buildup so when you don't
have enough b you're going to be
highly irritable edgy little things will
bug you you won't have very much
tolerance for stress
and a condition called sids sudden
infant death syndrome
that's a b1 deficiency because the
infant just stops
breathing in in his or her sleep it's b1
because of the b1 effect of the
respiratory centers
okay so let's go to the next part okay
so now why would you be deficient okay
mainly sugar refined sugar empty
calories
if you take two diabetics okay and
they're both consuming sugar
and one is deficient in b1 but the other
one is not
this diabetic will experience a lot of
the complications
of diabetes this one will experience a
lot less
so b1 helps prevent
the damage or at least the complications
or the symptoms
from high sugar okay carbs in general
because the more carbs you consume
the more b1 you need to metabolize those
carbs
white rice and this is a carb but i
wanted to put this there because it's
really how they discovered uh beriberi
white rice and all the b vitamins are on
the
the the hull okay so when you actually
take the hall out
so brown rice has the hall so they take
it out
and then you have this just pure
carbohydrate white rice
and then you consume that and you create
a vitamin b1
deficiency that's why if you actually
consume rice halls you would get b1 from
that but this is the waste product of
the white rice
alcohol that depletes b1 big ton
also heat like in pasteurization or
cooking food
you're going to destroy b1 aging
the older you are the lower b1 you're
going to have
all right diabetes okay so diabetics
are nearly always deficient in b1 that's
because b1
is intimately involved in the cell that
makes
insulin okay so if we have a problem
with that then we're going to actually
have a deficiency
something called polyphenols that would
be coffee
tea and wine so if you consume a lot of
coffee or tea
don't be surprised if you end up with a
b1 deficiency
especially if you get that jittery if
you drink a lot of coffee and you feel
that jittery that feeling
you just take some b1 it goes away
within about four minutes
okay gastric bypass you're going to have
a deficiency of b1 simply because
they're
they're taking out the first part of the
small intestine
well guess where b1 is absorbed the
first part of the small intestine
if you had a gastric bypass i would
recommend taking
more b1 to somehow get it absorbed okay
sulfites
can create also a b1 deficiency and also
raw
fish if you have liver damage you're not
going to be able to absorb
the b1 as well anti-acids and
antibiotics also deplete vitamin
b1 caffeine will deplete it and
if you don't have enough stomach acid
you also will not be able to absorb
b1 but it also takes b1 to actually help
you make
stomach acid so it's kind of like it
goes back and forth
vaccinations can trigger a b1 deficiency
and give the person pots okay there's a
certain
vaccine i'm not going to get into it too
much but you can look it up
you'll find a lot of data on it but
vaccinations will deplete your b1
now the foods that are high in b1 would
be
liver yeast both baker's yeast and
nutritional yeast
i like the nutritional yeast a little
bit better because
the taste of baker's yeast is not that
great and also it's hard to find the
quality
i now as far as the source of b1 i like
the nutritional yeast
unfortified i'm not opposed to you
taking
b1 by itself even if it's synthetic as
long as you take
either a natural source of b vitamins
with it
or if you just take nutritional yeast
with it because anytime you take like
one single vitamin
over a long period of time it could
deplete or throw out of balance the
other factors because
vitamin b is a complex it has a lot of
different vitamins
pork is high in b1 eggs
fish sunflower seeds rice halls
squash asparagus and seafood
okay and again if you wanted to know the
test that will determine if you're b1
deficiency
trans-ketoglyce okay that's the name of
it
it's hard to find a lab that will do
that on you tender calves
that's a good way to pick it up if you
reach down you grab your calf and it's
real tender
you could have a b1 deficiency and
increase effort to exercise so it really
takes a tremendous amount of effort
to start exercise so you just don't have
that get up and go
mojo okay and then take some b1 and then
if you feel better and all of a sudden
now you can exercise then you're good to
go
personally when i exercise i take uh b1
i might take like 100 milligrams
but then i'll take some nutritional
yeast at the same time and i'll i'll go
exercise
on my bike and i notice when i take the
b1
i can go a lot further in fact i
probably can double the workout
and i just feel like my body just has to
exercise it's very interesting
and that's basically kicking in that
that mitochondria
ben photome okay that's a fat soluble
version of b1 it is synthetic however
there hasn't been any side effects known
uh when they study this so
i think this is totally fine but again
make sure you take your nutritional use
with it just to make sure you have the
whole balance
but benfotamine is really important with
people that have
nerve problems or alzheimer's or any
parkinson's or any type of damage to the
brain with memory
because it innervates the brain 25
times more than the regular
b1 that you would get that's water
soluble because what they did is they
made b1 into a fat soluble so it
penetrates
the brain which is all fat and the
nerves so it's great for peripheral
neuropathy
so if you were going to take benfotamine
i would just take four
tablets or i think they come in capsules
just through the day
and you should probably gonna see some
great results especially
if someone has alzheimer's or
parkinson's or memory problems
you're going to see some great
improvement or peripheral neuropathy
all right i know it's a very long video
but i wanted to give you
all the aspects of b1 it's a very vital
vitamin
thanks for watching so i want to know
about what you think about this video
so please comment below and tell me what
you think